now mondays are so fun because we have
monica in the house and during the whole
commercial break we're just cutting up
yeah a homecoming weekend monica
wild times eh connie every mother and
father out there y'all know what i'm
talking about homecoming week was a heck
of a week wasn't it
oh yeah busy busy busy it was it was
like parental uber out there on the
valley roadways hey guys i hope you had
a great weekend thank you guys so much
for joining us for this edition of
mondays with monica i was so happy about
this lady it was exciting she is known
as the queen of broadway thank you very
much her name is christianne noel she
has a tony nomination under her belt as
well as two drama desk awards and two
helen hayes awards currently she is
gearing up to return to the cast of dear
evan hansen on broadway but christiane
also has found a second home right here
in vegas she mentors our kiddos at
positively arts
christine thank you so much for being
here today my goodness you have so much
going on how are you i am really good i
am so glad that you asked me to be a
part of this monica thank you oh are you
kidding me i am honored how does it feel
to be reunited with your peeps on
broadway
and hello dear evan hansen everybody and
their mother is talking about this on
broadway in theaters what gives tell me
about it well we um are getting ready to
go back into rehearsals at the end we're
now in october happy fall we're in
october at the end of this month we're
finally starting to get back into the
rehearsal studio and i think they are
hoping to open back up on broadway on
the fifth anniversary of the original
opening on december 11th wow and i'd say
we are all excited and a little nervous
and not sure exactly what's going to
happen you know with i mean we're all
really enthusiastic of the notion that
we're going to dive back in and
audiences are going to come back to new
york and broadway's going to thrive
again but i think we're all still a
little nervous about it we're not sure
where it's going to go a little birdie
told me that not only are you doing your
thing on broadway miss fancy pants i
read your resume i couldn't even fit it
into this interview by the way
but you have a connection here to las
vegas which as a mother i am so
appreciative uh i love that you have
connected here first of all tell me how
the connection happened to vegas and
what it is you actually do for our
kiddos in the community
well um my dear dear friend bill evans
uh was there with baz
on the strip
and uh he got involved with this amazing
organization called positively arts yeah
that uses um performance and arts
therapy and performing
to reach kids in all stages of of life
and all walks of life
and gives them the confidence to perform
to sing whether that is theatrically or
more of
pop singing it doesn't really matter but
getting up there and getting in touch
with their emotions he's a huge fan of
the
competition shows so he said we should
do something like that
and he contacted me because he's a big
fan of that and i'm kind of like
you know i watch a little bit of those
things like no you could be a mentor i
am so glad i did that it was amazing and
we kept seeing
the growth in these students that we
worked with but then we would watch the
videos of all the kids that were
involved
there is some amazing talent in las
vegas and these kids were so
enthusiastic and so jazzed and ready to
um step into their own power as it were
because maybe they hadn't been taught a
certain way or you hadn't been nudged to
say hey you know why don't you think
about it this way why don't you sing it
that way rather than just singing it the
way that you're making all these me this
music their own
that's when it's really exciting well
hey i i don't know if i'm supposed to
say it like this but uh when you return
to broadway i know you're in rehearsals
break a leg that's exactly right thank
you
ask her before that actually happened
i'm like i don't want to say anything to
give her bad luck uh but you know what
that dear evan hansen we wanted to dig
into it a little bit more but we
couldn't because broadway has rules you
know about a lot of their uh their shows
and they have their own pr team so we
just went a little bit into dear evan
hansen but folks hey we're going to
replay this on my facebook live tonight
don't forget to catch it at 7 pm it was
a fun interview john all right thank you
very much monica
we were talking very humble uh she was
very humble despite the fact that she's
a broadway superstar oh yeah helping
kids and doing the right thing that was
another great one monica thank you
appreciate it